はい ではよろしくお願いします
今日決めたのは八十七番目の経典です
これは長部 中部経典という
このまあいくらかこのまあ中ぐらいの長さっていう意味ですけど
中ってどうやって決めるかというと
長部経典があります あの経典の長さから測ってみると
これは中ぐらいになると
で 次のテキストはサングッティニカーヤは日本語で何？相応部というテキストのセットがあります
そちらの経典はこれよりも短いということで
ですから この経典が成立するというか
編集するときは そんな昔のお坊さんたちがものすごい真剣に
ということは ちょっと冗談みたいに
長いものは長いところにしましょう
中ぐらいのは中ぐらいのところにまとめましょうという
すごく気楽にしたんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
で 相応部っていうのは
やっぱりこのテーマごとにまとめて
例えば因果法則について語ったものは全部か所にまとめましょうというところで
それでまた小資 何でしたっけ
アングットラは 小資部というところがありますね
そちらはただ数字でまとめているんですね
いわゆるこの一つという言葉入っている経典一つ
二つが出てくる経典 三つが出てくる経典とかね
そういうふうな このまあこの編集する時はそれぐらいの枠組みで編集しているんです
まあそれはまあすごい軽々くやってますけど
決して経典そのものがもういい加減にみんなに編集できるようにとか
変えるようにとはしてないんですね
まあそこら辺はそのぐらいにして
で それからこの一つの経典読みますから
かなりブッダの思考とかね
ブッダ お釈迦様のものの見方とかね
は分かります で でも全て分かるということじゃないんです
経典 この中部経典の特色というのは
何か一つのテーマがあって
そのテーマはその経典の中でちゃんと扱ってみるという
ですから この中で政治に関わる経典もありますし
女性に関わるところもありますし
いろんな宗教の他宗教の論理ですか
それに対していろいろからくりやってる経典もあるし
業について語っている経典もあるし
それからまあ輪廻やらいろいろね
そういうところもあるし
厳密に心の問題だけあつけて扱って語っている経典もあるし
それで心の問題にしても
一般の人々の心の問題とか
修行するお坊さんたちの心の問題とかね
そうやってテーマごとに扱っているんですね
だから一般的に一つ経典を選ぶっていうことは大変難しいんです
とにかくこれは少々一般的なところだと思います
ではいきます ［外国語］で
それはこの経典の始まりのところで
アーナンダ尊者がこのように聞いたというところで
ある時お釈迦様がこのサーワッティーのジェーター
アーナンダビンディカ僧院に住んでいた時の話です
テーナコーパナサメーナ
その時アンニャタラスガハパティス
ある在家の人に いつでもこのガハパティは資産家という風に訳してますね
孤児とかですね  孤児 孤児でもよろしいしね
孤児の方が漢字としてしっかり出てますけどね
お墓なんかによく書いてる
[笑い]英語でもハウスホールドと言うんで
マスターオブザハウスというね
主人という意味なんですよ
だから奥さんに対して主人ではなくても
家の主人 日本語でよく旦那さんという言葉ありますね
それぐらいの意味なんですけどね
やっぱり旦那さんと言ったっても
やっぱり夫婦の間にも使ってるんですね
でもそれは一般のね みんな旦那さんという風に呼んだりするでしょうね
それちょっとした敬語でしょうしね
アーナンダビンディカ
孤児の場合は それは当然ながらすごい資産家でしたけどね
あ その 何だったっけ？ある資産家の一人息子がカーラカトホと死んでしまったと
で ピヨエーカプット それは可愛い
ピヨマナ―プっていうのは大変気に入ってるって意味なんですね
いわゆるこの場合は可愛いと訳しなくちゃいけないしね
愛しいですかね 愛しい一人息子が亡くなりましたと
タッサカーリキリ 彼が死んじゃったところでネーワカンマンタパティバンティ
この人は仕事もしないんですね
仕事をする気にもならない
ナバッタンパティバーティ
バッタンというのは食事のことで
ご飯という意味なんですね
一応 日本語でもご飯といえばライスって思い浮かぶし
インドでも同じことなんです
バッタンというのは本当はライスという意味なんですけどね
やっぱりご飯に使うんですね
食事として使ってる言葉です
パティバーティ もう食べる気にもならないと
で こちら日本訳としては手が空かなかったということですけどね
パティバーティというのは何かやりたいという気持ちが起こることですね
例えば何かアイディアが浮かんだら
その場合もパティバーティというんですね
[笑い]ですから前にカンマンタパティバンディそれは複数形で仕事といえばいろいろ仕事ありますから
その場合パティバンティ
ご飯は単数だからパティバーティとなっています
そう アーラハナンガントワ
彼がこのカソバニってアーラハナンというのはカソバニって
ガントワガントワ 行っては行ってはカンデティ
泣く カハンエーカプッタカ
私の息子はどこへ行ったかと
一人息子はね その場合もこのプッタは息子
カっていうのはこのちょっと見下す時も使う部品で
それから逆にもうすごい可愛いというね
意味でも使ってるんですね
そこでカハンエーカプッタカ
カハンエーカプッタカね
もう私の一人息子はどこへ行ったのかとでも言いながら
まあ泣くんですね そこでもうあとそれからそのガハパティがお釈迦様のところにいて
お釈迦様に礼をして座ったんですね
座ったらお釈迦様がエーカマンタンニシンナンコータンガハパティンバガワバガワエタドゥーチャ
このシサンカが喋る前にお釈迦様が話始まるんですよ
ナコーテーガハパティサケーチッテーティッタッティタッスインドリヤーニアッティ
まあ簡単日本語で言えば
あんたちょっとおかしいんじゃないかと
今日は という意味なんですけどね
サケチッテーというのは心
サケ ちょっと言葉を見てください
この一番目の段落の下から二行目のサケというのは自分の
チッテーというのは心
それで自分の心の中にまとめていないんですね
何をまとめていないんでしょうかというと
インドリヤーニ インドリヤーニというのは目耳鼻考え方とかなどなどなんですよ
目やら鼻やら耳やら口やらね
それから体のしぐさやら
それから思考 それはだいたいまとめてインドリヤと言うんですね
それは自分の心にちゃんとまとめておいてないんではないかということは
あんたおかしいということなんですね
こちらで座っても 心は他のところに行っていて
で 例えばお釈迦様の方を見ているんだけど
もう耳が他のところに行ったりとかね
そうやってもうちょっと調子がおかしいということなんです
テーインドリヤーニアンニャタッタン
あなたの六根はもうあっちこっちもう行ってるんではないかと
いわゆるお釈迦様に会う場合は
みんなものすごく心を何と言いますか
整えて お釈迦様を見て話をよく真面目に聞いて帰るんですね
それは別に当時の人々となんということではなくて
やっぱりこの残念ながらテープラコダもなかったし
もう紙もなかったし みんなただ行って話を聞くことだから
一回で全部覚えておかないと
だからみんなものすごい集中力はその点であったんです
だから話を聞いて理解する
それで私も勉強してた時はお金がなかったんで
大学の勉強している時でもものすごいもうお金もなくて
そうやって紙とか買うお金もなかったんです
で 友達がもう大学の印刷部で印刷工場みたいなところ
印刷屋さんがありますからね
そちらに仕事する友達がいて
この紙の原本とか印刷しちゃうと
この切り切っているところ捨てるでしょうね
そこはいくらかまとめてくれるんですね
それでメモ書くんですけどね
それは先生たちに見つけたらもう大変叱られちゃう
ちゃんとメモぐらい書きなさいとかね
言われるんだからね で
私は何をしたんですかというと
授業やらみんなの話やら真面目に聞いてるんです
いろいろディスカッションでなんとか本でなんとかこういう風にありますよと言ったら
私はそれをその場で全部覚えておくんです
そうするとメモない問題はもう解決しました
逆に誰よりもものすごいもう先生たちにも驚くほどの点数で
これぐらいこれのは点数は誰にも取れないよって驚くほどの点数を取ってしまっちゃうんです
図書館に行ったっても
いろいろ本を開けてみるんですね
開けてこうやってみて覚えておくんです
それもメモを取ってコピー取って
そんなお金がないんだから
だからそれで結構もう小さい時から勉強したものはなかなか忘れないんで
今は老化現象でもう全部もう忘れてはいるんだけど
ですから この これいろいろ物がないということはそんなに悪いことかと
今はそれから私はもう一応そういうものにね
コピー機械やらいろんなものに出会ってからは
何一つ覚えたことはないんです
何一つも それから本買ったりは買うこととか始めたんです
昔は本一冊も持ってなかったんです
でもほとんど知っている
本が新しく出ちゃうと
もう買った人からちょっとお願い
ちょっと貸してとか言って
すぐ貸してみて はい読了
なのでこちらは覚えてるんです
それから自分で買うんですね
自分で買った本も もしかすると一冊も終わりまで読んだことないと思います
だからもう何でしょうかね
豊かさというか それと一緒におらかさと貧しさと一緒に鋭さというようにセットになってるみたいです
まあまあ どっちにしても人間にやっぱり集中力ある場合はちゃんと頭っていうのはね
よくなることは確かなんですね
ですから昔の人々はそういうことはもう一般的でしたから
一回人の話を聞いたら
その一回で大体は覚えておくんですね
だからアナンダ尊者 これぐらい大量に経典を覚えたっていうのは
これちょっと嘘ではないかと今我々思うかもしれませんだけど
そんなことは嘘でもなんでもないんです
みんなに暗記能力あるんだから
その中でちょっと桁外れの人がいるっていうことは当たり前でしょうに
走る人の中ではカールルイスみたいな人々もいるんだからね
それは別に不思議なことでもないんです
そこで番目の段落の方を見ましょう
キンヒメーバンテインディリアナンナーニャタッタンバヴィセキ
キンヒメーバンテっていうのは何をおっしゃるんでしょうかというふうな意味なんですね
もう私の五根というか六根がね
変にならないわけじゃないんではないかと
日本訳はもっと立派にやっているでしょうね
どうして私の諸感覚に異変の起こらないことがありましょうか
そうですね マイハンバンテーエカプートーピュウマナポーカーラカと
私の一人息子が亡くなったと
彼が死んでから私はもう仕事にも手がつかないし
ご飯にも手がつかないし
私はもうもうもう何て言いますか
火葬場に行っては泣くと
それでお釈迦様は何のことなくエーワメータンガハパティ
あ それはその通りですよ
ピエジャアティカーガハパティソーカパルディワドッカドーマナスパヤサーピアッパパーラーティ
愛するものからですよ
苦しみ 悲しみ 憂いも嘆き
そんなものは愛するものから生まれるもんだよと
それ適切する日本訳ありますか
なぜなら 資産家よ 憂い
悲しみ 苦しみ 憂い 悩みは愛情から生じ
愛情から起こるからです
ソーカが心の憂い パルディワが悲しみ
ドッカが苦しみ ドーマナッサが憂鬱の憂い
そうですね ウパヤサーは悩み
いわゆる人間のね 苦しみ
悩み 悲しみ 憂い もう全てのもう精神的な問題っていうのは
まあ愛情から生まれるものだと
愛情っていうのは日本語ではそれしか書き方ないんですけど
ピヤっていうのは好きという気に入ってるということですね
好きなもの 気に入っているもの
ジャーティカっていうのはそのものから生まれるんだと
そこはお釈迦様はすごいこの疑問の言葉を言うんですよ
疑問生じる みんなもう怒って反対するような言葉はわさっと使っているんです
それもお釈迦様の一つ
その説法の仕方なんですね
で なぜならば このパーリ語で読む人々にはすぐ理解
こういうことを理解するんで
ピヤジャーティカっていうのは
自分の家族やら子供やらね
それからお金やら金銀宝石やら
もう自分に家があるんだったら自分の家やらね
すごい気に入ってる友達いるんだったら
そういう人間が欲しがるものなんですよ
ブランドの服やらカバンやらそういうものなんです
あれが好きですよとかね
だから同じ例えば同じカバンの中でも
やっぱり気に入っているものがありますね
日本ではデザインよりも名前ですからね
エルメスとかなんとか書いてるんだったら S
の文字で見たら じゃあこれいいというふうにね
というふうになってくると
それはやっぱり気に入ってるんですね
とにかく それは人間の感情だから
これ使えないんでと言ったっても
やっぱり気に入ってるものは気に入ってるんですね
それはしょうがないことで
だから本当は人間それで喜びを感じるんですよ
自分の大好物を食べ物が出てくると喜び感じるんであって
大嫌いな食べ物を自分の前でもう誰か用意しておいたってもね
なんと幸せかとは思わないんですからね
まあそういうことだから
その気に入るもの自体が人間の苦しみやと言っちゃうと
これ誰でも腹が立っちゃうんですよ
気に入るものが 好きなもの自体があんた方のもう苦しみの源大元ですよと言っちゃうと
そこで
彼の反応 カッサコナンエタンバンテエワンバビスティピエジャーティカソウカパリデワドッカドーマナスパヤサピヤパブイカピエジャーティカヒコバンテアナンダソウ
マナスサピヤパブイカアタコソガハパティバガワトバシタンアナビナンディットワパティッコシットワウッタヤサナパッカミ
そこでこのシサンガがカッサコナンナンエタンバンテ
そんなことありえないんだよだよと
尊師何をおっしゃるんですか
もう違いますよと お釈迦様に逆らえちゃうんです
好きなもの 気に入っているものがどうやって苦しみの元になるんですかと
苦しみ 悩み 憂いの元になるもんですかと
ピエジャーティカヒコバンテ
その好きなもの 気に入っているものこそではないか
アーナンダ喜び だからソウカの反対アーナンダ喜びですね
で パリデワっていうのは泣くこと
そちらの反対はソウマナス
またなんとなくもう楽しくてたまらないという気持ちですね
だからアーナンダソウマナス
喜び もう感激というかね
そういうものは好きなもの
気に入っているものが揃った時でしょうと
お釈迦様は間違っているんだと
もうものすごく反対されちゃうんですね
まあそれでこのお釈迦様っていうのはものすごい人間なのに
神々よりも尊敬されていたんですよ
もうたとえ国の王様であろうが
お釈迦様が言うことは聞くんであって
人々はあまり王様の話は聞かない
お釈迦様は他のことを言ったならば
それぐらい尊敬 各国で
インドの中で そんなに偉大なる人物でしたけど
いかにお釈迦様っていうのは立派な方というと
そうやって面と向かって反対
それ自分の信者さんなんで
弟子なんですよ それでももう大尊師であるお釈迦様にも「いえ
違います」と平気で言うんですからね
だけどそのすごいこの関係はね
ものすごく明るくて優しく
お互いにね まああった話なんで
状況なんですね 別にもう恐れて恐れてということはあまりなかったんです
尊敬はあったんだけど
余計な恐れはなかったんです
[咳払い]お釈迦様とはもう話は通じませんね
物別れになるんですね
アッタコウソウガハパティバガウトバアセタンアナビナンデとは
お釈迦様の言葉には賛成しないで喜びを感じないで
パティックコシット否定して
ウッタヤサナパッカミ
帰ってきたんですね 賛成もしないで否定して帰ってきたんです
テーナコウパナサメーマノシビノドコ
テーナ
コウパナサメーナサンバウラアッカドゥッタバガウトアビドゥーレアッキェヒディッバンティアタコウソウガハパティエーナテーアッカドゥッタテーヌパサンカミユパ
サンカミットワーテーアッカドゥッテエータダウォチャ
イ
ダハンボントーエーナサマノーゴートモテーヌパサンカミユパサンカミットワーサマナゴータマンアビワディットワーエカマンタンニシーディンエカマンタンニシンナン
コウマンボントーサマノーゴートモエータダウォチャエーノコーテーガハパティーサケーチッテーティッタッティタッサインドリヤーニャッティー
テーインドリヤーナンニャッタッタンティーエワマンゴッテーアハンボントーサマノーゴートマンエータダウォチャ
キンヒメーバンテーインドリヤーナンナーナーンヤッタンタッタンバヴィッサティーマイハンヒバンテーエーカプットー
ピヨ
マナポーカカトータッサカカキリアーエネーワカッマンタパティバンティーナバッタンパティバーティーソーアーラハナンガントワーガントワカンバーミーカハンエー
カプットカカハンエーカプットカーティーエーワメタンガハパティーエーワメタンガハパティー
ピヤジャーティカーヒーガハパティソーカパリデーワドゥッカドーマナッスーパヤーサピヤッパバウィカーティー
カッサコーナンナーンエータンバンテーエワンバヴィッサティーピヤジャーティカーソーカパリデーワドゥッカドーマナッスーパヤーサピヤッパバウィカーティーピヤ
ジャーティカーヒーコーバンテーアーナンダソーマナッサーピヤッパバウィカーティー
アタカーハンボントーサマナッスゴータマッスバシタンアナビナンディットワーパティックコシットワーウッタヤーサナパッカミーティー
まあそこでも長いところですけど
前のストーリーの繰り返しなんですね
で 彼が帰る 帰るところでもお釈迦様が住んでいたそのそこら辺で誰がいたっけ？あ
賭博 賭博師たちが集めていたんです
で 賭博やってるんですね
賭博というんですかね
あ そういうこと  サイコロによって遊んでいた
サイコロで  そのアッカという言葉だからアッカはサイコロかな
アッカドッタっていう一般的な賭博っていうことですけど
ちょっと AKKHAですけどね
アッカがサイコロです
うんうんうん  サイコロだね
アッカ 赤がサイコロ？ 赤って
Who does the dice of gambling gambling
のdice 赤なんですか
で 赤は本当にサイコロかということは
そういう事象によってちょっと信頼できませんですけどね
なぜならば こちらでサイコロにしたら
必ずこちらもサイコロになるし
これから十冊本が出たっても
ただ前のものの翻訳ばっかりですからね
車軸です 車の軸 車の軸
車軸 二が目  それは知ってますけど
この場合ね まあおそらく赤だと思いますかもしれませんね
とにかく回すものだからね
だからあれやるでしょ
gamblingって言うと
これなんか大きな丸いやつ
ルーレット あれも回すものだから
パーリ語で言えばアッカなんですよ
とにかくこの仏教の世界だけではなくて
インドの世界っていうのは
この賭博っていうのはもうすごい品のない気持ち悪いものだと
破壊の元やと思っていたんですね
ですから ジャータカ物語の中でも
このもう王様なんかね
そんな興味がそそったら
もう自分だけではなくて
国ごとに滅びますよ 滅びますよとというストーリーまで作ってるんですね
ですから このいろんな賭け事っていうのは
まああまり仏教は良くないとは思ってるんですね
それは一般的なインドの社会でもあまり良くないと思っているんです
だから このこれは皆様方観光する時もお分かりになると思いますけど
例えばタイやら台湾やら中国やら
そういうところに行ったら
この動物を戦わせて 魚を戦わせてお金を賭けるという
っていって そういうお金取るんですね
で そういうインドに見てみたら
ただ猿回しをして ヘビをなんか何とかしてとか
そういうお金取ってるんですね
だからそこはやっぱりgamblingではないんですよ
あるいは何とか占いでもして
もう何とかして 何とかちょっとアクロバティックでもしてあげて
ちょっとお金ちょうだいと
貧しい人々はそういうことでお金儲かってというか
商売しているんですね
で 誰もでも例えばこの鶏持ってて
じゃああんたいくら賭ける？あんたいくら賭ける？とか
それは全くないということはもうない
ありえないんだから もう一般的にはない
例えばタイは仏教の国なんですけど
やっぱりもう民衆はね
もう半分以上中国血統の人々でしょうしね
ですから タイやら台湾やらそこら辺に行ってみればね
そういう賭博系統のはよくあります
インド文化ではなかなかまあまあコソコソあちこち隠れてやるところありますけど
それ自体は批判されちゃうんですね
で 仏教ではものすごくこれはもう禁止しているんですね
それで金儲かるなよと
これは泥棒だからね 何か仕事をして金儲かってるわけじゃないでしょうに
これこちらで赤ですよと
じゃあもうね  一万賭けますよと
じゃあ私は黒に賭けますよと言ってね
それで人の一万円奪っちゃっても
それはもう泥棒のいいところなんですね
ですから そんなことで食べてはいけませんと
ちゃんと仕事しなさいと
何かものを作って それはまあ人に売ってでも
なんとか物々交換してでも生活しなさいというのが仏教の考え方なんですね
ですから 仏教では医療は認めていて
教育はすごく褒めてあって
それから農業は一番褒めてる農業な仕事としては彼らが一番偉いと
で まあ農業の次には商売とか入りますけどね
それからいろんな加工芸術ですね
技術芸術という世界ですね
で 例えば自分で何か技を身につけて
それを見せてお金儲かることには何も言いません
その人はそれに対して修行してるんだからね
例えば一時間逆立ちしているぞとかなんと言ったっても
一時間逆立ちしたままでいるには
やっぱりそれなりの修行必要でしょうしね
だったらまあいいわ お金いくらあげたってもとか
見る側もそれ見て楽しいということになっちゃうしね
そういうものはあまり否定しません
賭博はもうけしからんだと
だからこの品格ない このカーストの一番低い人々たちがやるものだという風に
もうその場合 そのカーストの使っている差別用語まで使っちゃうんです
否定するために そこで彼らが賭博していて
そのそこら辺通して このこの人どうしても帰らなくちゃいけないんですね
で 彼がどうせちょっと暇があって
暇があるというかね 自分の気持ちが落ち着いてないんだからね
毎日毎日お墓に行ってね
泣いていた人が もうなんとかならないかと思ってお釈迦様のところに行ったら
もう話し合いにならなかったんですね
お釈迦様と喧嘩して帰っちゃうんですね
だからお釈迦様から全然もう何も心を慰める言葉を聞くことはできなかったし
それで時間があるんだからね
それでその人々のところにちょっと腰かけて
その人々にその話を言ったんですね
私はお釈迦様に会ったところで
こういうふうなことを言われちゃった
私は反対して帰ったぞと
偉そうに威張って言うんですね
それから次の段落に行きます
エーメタンガハパティエーメタンガハパティピエジャティカーヒィガハパティアーナンダソウマナッサピヤッパバヴィカーティ
それでこの賭博師たちがエーメタンガ
それはその通りですよ
もうと言うんで それはその通りですよ
あんたおっしゃる通りですよと
好きなものこそ 人間にとって喜び
幸せを与えてくれるんではないかと
もうやっと賛成する人々を見つけたんです
仲間が 仲間が見つけたところで彼に彼が気づくんですよ
アタコウソウガハパティサメティメーアッカドゥッテヒイティアッカメ
で この居士があ 私の意見は賭博師とはよく合いますよと思って帰ってしまったんです
彼が彼に本当はすごく恥じかけられちゃったんですよ
だから自分の意見にお釈迦様みたいな偉大なる人々は賛成しません
一番社会のこの一番低級の次元でいる賭博師とはピッとはめるんです考え方
これ決して決して自慢にならないんですよ
自分の意見だったらね
ヤクザとか犯罪者だったら賛成しますよと言ったら
それ自慢話にはなれませんだからね
だから彼にはどうにもならなくなっちゃったんです
そのまま帰っちゃって帰ってしまったんです
アタコーイダンカタワットゥンアヌプッベーナラージャンテープランパーヴィセイ
この居士がお釈迦様と喧嘩して帰っちゃって
それから自分の考え方
賭博してぴったしはめてしまっちゃったんだと
もう一応大恥かきられたという
この話がね もうあっちこっちもう流れていって
王様のところにも行ってしまったんです
王様で言ったっても この宮殿のね
人々の間でも話題になったんですね
アタコーラージャーパセーナディコーサローマッリカンデーヴィーアーマンテーシ
コーサラ王様が自分の一番気に入りの奥さんがいるんです
マッリカという その大の気に入りのマッリカ夫人とよくしゃべるんですよ
マッリカ夫人というのはものすごい仏教の信者さんで
もうかなりの頭がいいんです
だから王様 には奥さんたちはいっぱいいっぱいいたんだけど
みんなただもうね もう女性っていうのはね
私って可愛いっていう感じばっかししかないんだから
王様にとってはちょっと面白くないんですね
おしゃれをして もうなんとかかわいがって欲しがってるだけで
マリカ夫人はそこら辺はそんなないんですね
もう言いたい時は言うし
すごいもう管理やら何でもするし
王様が何か言ったらもうそれはそうではないんではないかとかも言ったりもするし
そこら辺が王様にもすごい気に入ってるんですね
やっぱり何かあったらもう自分の悩みとかなんとかあったから
二人でこそこそこそこそと喋っている
だって大臣たちでも王様だからね
相手が王様だからね 恐れたこと言えないでしょうね
これ奥さんだからもう何でも言う
そういうところで王様も国を管理しなくちゃいけないし
自分に何か問題あったら
まあちょっと後ろに行ってごそごそとマリーカ夫人と喋ると
彼女はちゃんと教えてくれるんですね
ですから 大体二人がいつでも一緒にいるんです
そういう夫婦関係なんです
で マリカ夫人にその話を言うんですね
イダンテーマッリキー
その場合はちょっとお前って意味なんですね
マッリカ サマネーナゴーテメーナバシタン
ピエジャティカソーカパルジェワドゥクコドゥーモナスパヤサピヤッパバウィカーティ
王様にもこれちょっと賛成できないんですよ
だって好きな宝石やら好きな人々やらいっぱいいた方が楽しいでしょうに
だからお前マッリカ知ってますかね
もう釈迦さんがこんなこと言ったよと
そこでマリカ夫人の反応はサチェタンマハラジャバガターバシタンエワメタンティ
もし王様 それがお釈迦様おっしゃったならば
だったらその通りですよ
何のことなく それがお釈迦様おっしゃっただったらそれ通りですよ
ものすごい簡単に決めちゃうんですね
だからマリカ夫人がかなり修行もしているし
だからブッダの智慧に対しては一かけらも疑いがないんです
だから自分の頭が頭の悪さに分からなくても
お釈迦様おっしゃったんだから絶対無駄話は言わんぞということをもうはっきり確認しているんですね
確信があるんですね だからそう言うんですね
エワメワンパナヤンマッリカヤンヤデーヴァサマノゴートモバサティタンタデーヴァアッサアッバヌモーダティ
サチェーワンマハラジャバガターバシタンエワメタンティ
これで王様が怒るんですけどね
セイ
エターピナーマアーチャリオヤンヤデーヴァアンテーバーシッサバシタタンタデーヴァアッサアンテーバーシアッバヌモーダティエワメタンアーチャリオエワメタンアーチ
ャリアティエワメワコオトワンマッリキーヤンヤデーヴァサマノゴートモバサティタンタデーヴァアッサアッバヌモーダティサチェーワンマハラジャバガターバシタン
エワメタンチャラピレーマッリキーウィナッサーティ
王様がえらく怒るんですね
で 王様こう言うんですね
まああんたマッリカーね
何かお釈迦様がおっしゃるんだったら
お釈迦様が何か言ったら
いつでもはいはい その通り
その通りやと そればっかしやと
バカではないかって意味なんですね
ちょっと自分でも考えたらどうですかと
これは誰かの若者が弟子入りすれば
誰かの先生のところに先生言うことを何でもはい先生
はい先生 はい先生 その通り
その通りだということと同じだと
だからあなたもお釈迦様が何かおっしゃったら
はい その通りです その通りですと
だからチャラピレーマッリキー
チャラピレーマッリキー
これはすっごい軽視なんです
その言葉は レーという言葉
ジェという言葉とかありますね
ものすごくこと ものすごいもう軽視の言葉でお前出ていけと
ウィナッサーティっていうのは
まあ本当は亡くな死んでしまえっていうことですね
英語ではユーゴートゥーヘルって言うでしょ
まあもう人を気に入らない人を言うことはね
もう全く賛成できない
その場合はユーゴートゥーヘルと言っちゃうでしょうね
地獄に落ちれってことでしょ
それは普通意味はもうあんた言うことは認めませんよって意味なんですね
あるいはダムユーという言葉ありますでしょ DAM
ですね ダムユー それはものすごいきつ言葉なんですよ
だからダムネーションという動詞があるんですよ
それはキリスト教で禁止しているんです
それは神様にしかない権利なんです Damn
というのはこの最後の審判で
キリストを神様を信じている人だけを天国に入れて
神様を信じていない人々はみんな地獄に行きなさいと
このcondemnationするんですね
あれは え？非難でもない
え？この車とかもう使えないというふうに何か決めるでしょ
あれなんて言いますか
処分  処分ではない 処分は後のことだから
まずそれその認可というかね
はい 廃車認定 廃棄 廃棄処分
それはもう廃棄処分だからね
区役所に行って何か廃車
なんとか なんか登録とかなんとかするんですよ
廃棄処分 え？抹消 うん
それは抹消 抹消っていうのは登録抹消ですね
うん で とにかくそういうやり方ありましてね
そういうふうにこの まあその場合condemnという英語の
英語の言葉ですけど とにかくDamnというのはその言葉なんですけど condemn
というのはもっとかっこいい言葉なんですね
だからDamnというのはすごい品のない言葉だから使わない
英語で 人を叱る時だけね
使っちゃいますけどね
それ以外は使わない でも普通の英語の動詞なんです
あれは だから大体英語を勉強する人は使う場が何もないんだから
使い方がわからないだろうと思いますけどね
だからそれはもう聖書では神様だけやることなんです
最後に ですから 人に我々はその言葉を使っちゃうと
これは神を冒涜することであって
大変な悪いことなんです
それ禁止しているんだけど
だから一般英語でそれ使っているんです
人をバカにするためで Damn
youとかね それよりも今はHellという言葉ですね
使っているのはね だからこの場合はもうお前消えろというふうなね
という意味で well
亡き者と 日本語訳はどういうふうに訳していますかね
え？あ 下がれ うん 下がれ
下がれ それはしょうがないんですからね
この場合はね もうマーリカーデーヴィーに怒られちゃって
マーリカーデーヴィーも追い出されちゃって
またすごい非難の言葉で
マーリカーデーヴィー仏教徒だからそんなことでは逃げない
とにかく攻撃する で 彼女はそこに次の企みをするんです
[笑い]アタコ・マッリカー・デーヴィー・ナーリジャンガ・バーラモナ・アーマンテーシ
エー
ヒ・トワム・バーラモナ・エーナ・バガヴァーテーナ・プサンカム・プサンカミットワー・ママ・ワチャレーナ・バガヴァート・ウパデー・シリーサー・ワンダーヒ・
アッパ・バーダン・アッパ・タンカン・ラウッタナン・バラン・パス・ヴィーハラ・プッチェ
マ
ッリカー・バンテー・デーヴィー・バガヴァート・ウパデー・シリーサー・ワンダティ・アッパ・バーダン・アッパ・タンカン・ラウッタナン・バラン・パス・ヴィー
ハラ・プッチャティーティ・エヴァンチェ・ヴァデーヒ・バシタ・ヌコ・トゥンメ・バンテー・バガヴァタ・エーサー・ワーチャ・ピーヤ・ジャーティカ・アショーカ
・パリ・デーヴァ・ドゥッカ・ドーマナ・スーパヤ・サピーヤ・アッパ・バヴィカーティ・ヤター・ジャテー・バガヴァー・ヤー・カーローティ・タン・サードゥカン
・ウッガ・ヒトワー・ママン・アーロ・チェーヤーシ・ナヒ・ター・タター・ガター・ヴィタタン・バナンティーティ・
エヴ
ァン・ボー・ティーティ・コー・ニーラン・ジャンゴー・ナーリ・ジャンゴー・バーラモナ・マッリカー・デーヴィアー・パティ・スッタワー・エーナ・バガヴァー・テーナ・プサンカミ
そこでマッリカー・デーヴィーのたくらみはもうナーリジャンガという名前のバラモンがいた
宮殿の中でバラモンたちがいるんですね
みんな知識人たちだから
いろんな場合アドバイスするやら法律の調べやら
いろんなことをやっている人々はいるんですね
で そのナーリジャンガという
これ名前おかしいんだけどね
ジャンガっていうのはこのあれでしょ
膝から下の部分 ふくらはぎですね
ナーリっていうのはこの壺なんですね
かなり丸い大きい壺って意味なんですね
だから  ふくらはぎの大きい人
という意味になりますけどね
でも ふくらはぎは壺のようということだからね
そんな名前をつけるかどうかわかりませんですけどね
まあ恐らくかなり太っていたでしょうね
だいたい背が短いんだったらふくらはぎの方が太くなっちゃうんですね
背が高い人の場合はふくらはぎが細いということもあります
ですから どれでもいいけどですけどね
どうちゅうなっても偏見だからね
名前はちょっとおかしいんですけどね
ただそれだけ インドではお釈迦様にはエーニジャンガンという言葉を使ってますね
エーニっていうのはある鹿なんですね
鹿のふくらはぎのようだと
ということはかなり細いってことなんです
ある一種類の鹿なんですけど
すごく足が細くてすごい美しいんですね
形が お釈迦様の足もものすごく細いんだと
ですから こちらナーリジャンガといえば逆ですからね
そのバラモンに バラモンを呼んで
お釈迦様に会いなさい
会って マッリカー夫人がお釈迦様に挨拶礼をしますと言って
挨拶礼をしなさいと それからお釈迦様はお元気ですか？とかね
調子はいかがでしょうかと
お釈迦様の健康のことも聞きなさいと
それからお釈迦様にこれを報告しなさい
お釈迦様がこの好きなものこそが
人間にとっては苦しみ
悩み 憂いが招くんだよとおっしゃったんでしょうと
お釈迦様は決して それでお釈迦様が何を説明するか
それは全部覚えておいて私に報告しなさい
釈尊は決して無駄話はしませんと
そこはパーリ語のところ見てください
真ん中辺ですけどね ナヒ・タター・ガター・ヴィタタン・バナンティーティ
ほぼ真ん中のところでナーリジャンガという言葉あります
その上の行ですね ナヒ・タター・ガター・ヴィタタン・バナンティーティ
タター・ガターっていうのはニルライタチという複数形ですね
いわゆる悟った人々がヴィタタン
事実でないもの いわゆる具体性
合理性 論理性ないものはナ・バナンティ
喋りません いわゆる釈尊がブッダが何か言ったら
それはまるっきりその通りのことで
いわゆる感想としても何も喋れません
希望的観測でも何も喋れません
可能性では何も喋れません １００
パーセントの事実のみ語るというすごい性格があるんですね
ですから それはマッリカー夫人はしっかり知っているんだからね
お釈迦様から説明聞きなさいよと
そこで彼もはいそうですと言って
お釈迦様に会って もう繰り返しちゃうんですね
お釈迦様に 報告すると言ったら
お釈迦様の言葉エバメタン
ブラームナ エバメタン
ブラームナ ピエ ジャティカーヒ
ブラームナ ソーカ パリデヴァ
ドゥッカ ドゥーマナス
ウーパヤーサ ピヤッ パ
バヴァーティ それでバラモンよ
その通りです その通りですよと
好きなものから人間に苦しみ
悩み 憂いが生まれてくるんだと
言って それからお釈迦様は説明に入るんですよ
だから 前のバラモンというか
前の資産家が頭がもうもうそんな調子じゃないんだから
お釈迦様に説明聞くことところに行かなかったんだよ
自分の息子のことでも頭いっぱいでしたからね
だから本当はお釈迦様に相談していたならば教えてくれたのにね
ただ見な ただ見なアペー
タン ブラームナ パリヤーエナ
ヴェーリ タッバン ヤター
ピヤ ジャーティカ ソーカ
パリ デーヴァ ドゥッカ
ドゥーマナス ウーパヤーサ
アッパ バヴァーティ で
その これはこのように理解してください
好きなものから憂い悲しみ生まれるんだということは
このように理解してください
ブータ プッバン ブラームナ
イミサーエワ サーヴァッティア
アンニャ タラッサ イッティヤ
マーター カーラン アカーシェーサー
タッサー カーラ キリヤーヤ
ウム アッティカー キッタ
チッター ラティヤーヤ
ラティヤン シンガータケーナ
シンガータカン ウパ サンガ
ミッアーエワ マーハ アピメ
マーターラン アッド サタ
アピメ マーターラン アッド
サターティ あるストーリーを言うんですよ
ある日 このサーワッティ町町で
ある女の人の母親が死んだったと
その母親が死んだったところに
その女の娘がウンマッティカ
頭が狂ってしまって キッタ
チッター それも頭が狂ったことの同じ同義語なんですね
それ何か日本語ありますかね
発狂し 次が心が錯乱し
錯乱してね いわゆる錯乱してね
だから頭が狂ってしまったんですね
狂ってまたラティヤー
ラティヤー ラティヤン
まあ道から道へですね
シンガータケーナ シンガータカンっていうのは
まあいろいろ十字路 十字路から十字路へとかね
いわゆる十字路っていうのは大体人が集まる場所だから
大きい場所ですね あっちこっち行ってて皆あっちこっち行きながら探すんですね
母親を アピメ マーターラン
アッド サタ 私の母に 母見ましたか？母を見ましたか？とかね
頭を狂ってしまっちゃって
でお釈迦様イミナアピ
コウ エタン ブラームナ
パリヤーエナ ヴィパ だからそういうことを見たらわかるでしょうにと
あの女の子 女の人が自分の母のことをものすごく好きで
好きで 突然死んじゃったところで頭がおかしくなっちゃったと
おかしくなっちゃって
お母さん見つけたの？お母さんいるの？お母さんいるの？と言っても
お母さん探してるんですね
ずっと だからお釈迦様が今出したこの実例っていうのは
ある人が完全に狂ってしまったということ
だから昔はなかったんだから
今だったらもう病院に連れて行って
そこでもう閉じ込まれるしか方法ないんですね
それでもう一つストーリー
［外国語］もうまたもう同じ繰り返しですけどね
ある女の人の父親が亡くなった時もそうなったと
もう兄弟が亡くなった
もう男の兄弟が亡くなった時もそうなりましたと
で 女の兄弟が亡くなって
またある女の人がそうやって狂ってしまったと
ある女の人の息子が亡くなってとかね
娘が亡くなって 旦那が亡くなって
それも一つのケースなんですね
だから一つのケースですけど
これはこのこういうことなんですよ
例えばたった一人だけ自分の誰かが亡くなって頭が狂ったのならば
それはそれでいいんですよ
そんなものはそこら中あるんですね
母が亡くなったと頭が狂った人やら
旦那が亡くなったと頭が狂った人やら
娘が亡くなったと頭が狂ってる人やら
息子が亡くなったと頭が狂ってる人やら
私の弟が死んじゃったと言って頭が狂っちゃうもうお姉ちゃんやらね
いくらでもいることなんですね
当時でももうサーワティって言えばもうものすごい大きな地方だから
そこら中もういっぱいいたことなんですね
たくさんそういうケースがね
一応いろいろ戦いやら戦争やらそういうものもあったでしょうし
そういうところでもね
まあ人を殺されちゃうし
だからやっぱり残って残された人々にとってはもう並ならぬショックでしょうね
それでもう頭狂ってしまっちゃうんです
［外国語］そこでもう一つケース出すんですね
その場合は男なんですね
だから一応女性の方々
なんで女ばっかり狂っちゃうでしょうかと思うかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり仏教は平等で平等で
ちゃんと五分五分で例を出すんです
それで同じサーワティで
このある男の人の母親が死んじゃうんですね
その男の人が頭狂っちゃって
あっちこっち歩き回るんですね
私のお母さん見つけたんですか？お母さん見つけたんですか？とか
だから男も狂っちゃうんですね
そこで次のセットも同じなんですね
ある男の父親が亡くなって
ある男のお兄ちゃんが亡くなって
お姉ちゃんが亡くなってとかね
ある男の奥さんが亡くなってとかね
ですから この好きな人に別れた時は
苦しみは男にでも女にでも同じですよと
頭狂っちゃうと言えば男も頭狂っちゃうし
女も頭狂っちゃいますよということをこちらに透けているんです
［外国語］一応そこでお釈迦様はこれは一般的なもんだよと
男であろうが女であろうが
すごい好きな大好きな人から別れると
自分の頭がおかしくなって狂ってしまっちゃって
常識もなくなって それで自分の人生も台無しになるんだよということで
ちゃんとバランスをとるための証拠を出すんですね
そこにもう一つのケースが出てくるんですね
［外国語］
イメマンアイヤプッテニャタカタンアッチンディットワアンニャッサダトゥカマアハンチャタンナイッチャミーティアタコソプリソタンイッテンディダチェットワアッ
タナンウッパテーシウボペッチャバヴィッシャーミーティイミナピコタンブラフマナパーヤーエナヴェーリタブバンヤターピヤジャーティカショーカパーディヴァドゥッカドゥーマナスパヤサーピヤッパバヴァーティ
で それはどんな これはまあストーリーどこにありますかね
三百ページ はい  バラモンの旧時代
このサーヴァッティーにおいて
ある女性が親族の家にいましたというところですね
彼女の親族は彼女を夫から奪い
他に与えようとしました
しかし 彼女はそれは望みませんでした
そこでその夫の男に抗議しました
旦那様 これらの親族が私をあなた様から奪い
他に与えようとしています
しかし 私はそれは望みませんと
するとその男性は死後に一緒になろうと
その女性を二つに切断し
身から置き去りました
で バラモンはこの行為によってもその憂い
悲しみ 苦しみ 憂い 悩みはあり得ると
それちょっと皆様は理解できないところかもしれませんね
だから ある女の子 女の人がやっぱりまあ家にいるんですね
その旦那もいるんですね
いわゆる旦那の家ですけどね
そこで家のこの姑さんたちやらね
そのだいたいインド社会っていうのは
まあもう嫁もらってよっても
やっぱり年上の人々にはいつでも権利がありますからね
で この男の人のね 老人たちがこの女の人を他の家に嫁に出したかってるんですよ
おかしいでしょうに もうとっくに自分の息子と結婚しているんだから
だからそれは昔 そういう女性にはインドの文化では自由がなかったんですね
本当は これ仏教初めて
まあ何とかして これはもう科学的じゃないんだと
男も女も同じ人間という立場を取ったんですのは仏教だけなんです
で まあジャイナ教でもいくらかね
女性に立場がありましたけどね
やっぱりお釈迦様ほど力強く大胆にこの革命を起こしても
もう社会の習慣壊すところまではやっぱりできなかったんですけどね
お釈迦様はちゃんと堂々と
もうこの女性差別に対してはまあ抗議はしているんです
ですから インドの社会習慣でしたと思いますけどね
おそらく私の頃 私のいい加減な推測なんですけど
もしかするとこの女に子供がなかった可能性あります
だからインドはもう結婚させるのは子供のためなんです
だからインド人にとっては
この自分の家の子孫続くことこそが一番ありがたい大事なことであって
他の人々は別にどうでもいいんです
子供さえ作ってくれれば
それで子供を産んだならば
その母親に初めてその家の立場が成り立つんですよ
その人がその家の子供を育てて大きくしなくちゃいけないんだからね
そうすると家の必要な人物になってくるんです
子供がいなかったならば
何の立場もないんです
それでもしかすると この両親がそれほどすごいお金があるんだったら
二番目のお子さんもらっちゃえばいいんだけど
まあめんどくさいと この人にお金ご飯食べさせるなと
だから誰か他の人にあげましょうということで
どこかにも好き勝手にあげたがってるんですね
でも その女の人は絶対行きたくないんですね
他のところに この夫婦はものすごくお互いに愛情なんですね
ですから この女の人に言う相手もいないし
自分の旦那に言うんですね
私はもうこうやって他の家に出したがってるんだよと
私は死んでも行きたくないんだと
あなたから離れてと 言ったら旦那さんもやっぱりこの奥さんのことをね
すごく心配して しょうがないんだと
父親に母親に逆らうこともできないし
それでもう二つにもう切ってしまっちゃうんですね
もう自分のお子さんを切って自分も死ぬ
じゃあ私は死んでから一緒になりましょうと
だからすごい愛情でしょ
結局すごい愛情でどうなったかというと
二人とも死んでしまっちゃったんですね
だからお釈迦様はすごく冷静に問題を見るだけ
そこで素晴らしい愛の物語を語っているわけじゃないんです
それはもう普通の俗世間のくだらん人間に
そういうストーリーが見つけたら
これを増やして増やして
もういくらでも映画一つも作られますからね
ちょっとインドの文化背景ぐらい知ってるならばね
それだけのストーリーです
で これ美しい愛の物語だということになります
お釈迦様から見ればとんでもないんだと
結果としては二人が死んだでしょうと
そこで続きに行きます
アタコーニラジャンゴブラフマノ・バガヴァト・バーヒタン・アビナンディトワ・アヌモーディトワ・ウッタヤーサナー・イェナ・マッリカー・デーヴィー・テーナ・
プサンカー・プサンカミトワ・ヤーヴァタコー・アホシ・バガヴァタ・サッディン・カタ・サッラーポ・タン・サッバム・マッリカー・デーヴィー・ヤー・アローチェ
ッシー・アタコー・マッリカー・デーヴィー・イェナ・ラージャ・パセナディ・コーサラ・ロー・テーナ・プサンカー・プサンカミトワ・ラージャナン・パセナディ・コーサラ・イエタダ・ゴーチャ
まあそれでこのその説法をね
聞いて このバラモン人がちゃんと覚えてマッリカー・デーヴィーに報告する
マッリカー夫人に報告する
デヴィーと言ったら なんか日本人の誰かいるんだからね
で マッリカー夫人がそれで王様のところに行って
こういうふうに話すんですね
マッリカー夫人も本当にずるいんですよ
私はお釈迦様からちゃんと説明聞いていただけましたということは言わないんです
逆に自分の言葉に入れ替えちゃうんですね
それが智慧のある人の生き方なんですよ
ブッダの教えはちゃんと自分で一人で消化できるというね
ああ なるほど そういう理屈ですかと
だったらあっちこっち応用編はいつでも自分にできるんだという
だから彼女は本当に智慧の人で
で 王様にこう聞くんです
ピアテ・ワジリ・クマーリ
ワジリっていうのは王様の娘なんです
クマーリっていうのはプリンセスという意味なんです
プリンセスは  王女  ワジリ王女があんた好きですか？と言ったら
その通り イェ・ワム・マッリキ
好きですよと ピアメ・ワジリ・クマーリ
それはもうすごく可愛いんですよと
タンキン・マンニャシ・マハラージ
あんた
どう思いますか？ワジリヤーヤテ・クマーリヤー・ウィパリーナマ・アンニャター・バーワー・ウッパッジェッヨン・ソーカ・パリデワ・ドゥッカ・ドーマナッス・パーヤー・サーテ
あんたどう思いますかね？ワジリ王女が何か病気になったり
死んだりしちゃうと 何かね
大変なこと ウィパリーナマっていうのはもうこれどうやって訳すればいいんですかね
変化や異変と書いてありますけど
変化や異変でもよろしい
一応死ぬところまでそこで考えてるんですね
何か病気になったり 死んだりしたならば
あんたどう思います？あなたに悲しみとぐらい生まれますかと
あんたいいよね あんたワジリ王女が好きですか？ものすごい好きですよと
あんたどうですかね ワジリワジリ王女でね
何かね 病気やら変化やらね
死んだりしちゃうと あんた悲しむぐらいしますかねと聞いちゃうと
ワジリメーマッリケーくまりあヴィパリーナマンニャターバーワーバハヴィタッサピシアアンニャタッタキンパナンメーナウ
ッパジッサンティソーカパリデーヴァアパーヤーサーヤーティ
えーと まあそこ答えちょっと読んでください
その通りだ マッディカーよ
余はワジリ王女を愛しておる
大王様 そのことをどう思われますか？つまり
ワジリ王女に変化や異変があれば
あなた様にも憂い 悲しみ
苦しみ 憂い 悩みがおこるのかということです
マッディカーよ ワジリ王女に変化や異変があれば
余の生活にも異変があるであろう
どうして余に憂い 悲しみ
苦しみ 憂い 悩みがおこらぬことがあるか
ということで  彼女に何か何かあったらね
私にも私の心もおかしくなっちゃいますからね
なんで憂い悲しみが生まれないと思いますかっていう風にも反論するんですね
そこで彼女がイダンコータンマハーラジャテーナバグタージャーナターパッサターラハタサッマサンブッデーナサンダーヤバーキタン
こういうことについて
あのお釈迦様がジャーナターパッサター
物事を知って理解して
アラハンになったサッマサンブッダになったお釈迦様が
そのことについてお話をしているんだと
ピヤジャーティカーソーカパリデーヴァドゥッカドゥーマヌスパーヤーサーピヤッパバヴィターと
パーティ 好きな愛する者から憂い悲しみが生まれるんだっていうことは
そういうことでおっしゃってるんではでしょうと
そこで王様がまんまと負けるんですね
先に言わせてもらっちゃいますから
ワジリ王女が好きですかと
好きです ワジリ王女に何かあったらあんた悲しむぐらいしますかと
彼女もワジリ王女に何かあったら私は頭まで崩れちゃいますが
なんで悲しみはないんでしょうかと
言わくって言うでしょうに
だからお釈迦様そういうことをおっしゃってるんだ
次にまた聞くんですね
タンキンマンジュスマハーラジャピヤーテーワーサバーカッティヤーティ
で ワーサバーという息子
それはなんでカッティヤーと使ってますかというと
このおそらくこの王様がシャカシャカシャカ族じゃないんですよ
だからもうあのワーサバーっていうのは
あの お釈迦様の親戚なんですね
で 親戚の女の子を強引に結婚して
こうする王様がね お釈迦様の親戚関係作らなくちゃあかんと
それすごいトラブっちゃったんだけどね
後で  [笑い]だからこのワーサブ王子に対してはもうカッティアという言葉つけちゃうんですね
まあちょっと家はもうちょっと王様の家ではちょっと上という感じで
まあカッティといえばコーサラ王様はカッティでカッティっていうのはこの王家の人々みんなカッティと言うんですけど
このシャトリヤ族の中でもシャカ族の方がまあカネランクは上でしたからね
で コーサラ王様がもうシャトリヤだけで留まることを気に入らなくて
もうシャカ族の親戚にもなりたかったんですね
お釈迦様の家族の親戚ということで
すごい一般的なまあ凡人もいいところですよ
このコーサラ王様は で
とにかくこのシャカ族からもらったお嫁さんにも息子が生まれたので
その息子の名前をワーサブですね
それはあの王子ですね
あなたはそのワーサブ王子のこと好きですかと聞いたら
また好きですよと まあなんとかなったらあなたも悲しみますかと言ったら
まあそれはもう悲しみますよと言ったら
またそういうことについてお釈迦様が話をしましたと
そこでお釈迦様 王様にもう一人いたんですね
ヴィドゥーダバ・セーナーパティ
ヴィドゥーダバ・セーナーパティというのは
この軍隊の一番上の将軍ですね
それも王様の息子なんですね
それまた気に入りの息子で
で その人に何かなったらどう思いますかと言えば
これすごい悲しみますよと
まあそういうことについて
お釈迦様が好きなものから憂い悲しみが生まれるんだよとおっしゃったんですかと
ですと 最後に子供を先に出して
子供三人を先に出して
最後に彼女のことを言うんですね
タン・キン・マンニャシ・マハーラジェ・ピアテー・アハンティ
あなた私のことを好きですかと
エーワ・マッリキー・ピアメーシ・トアンティ
あなたのことをものすごく好きですよと
タン・キン・マンニャシ・マハーラジェ・マイ・ハンテー・ヴィパリーナ・マンニャターバーワ・ウッパッジャヤヨン・ソーカ・パリデーワ・ドゥッカ・ドーマナス・パーヤーサーと
もし私に何かあったら
あなたもう悲しむぐらいのことをしますかと言ったら
トゥイ・ハン・ヒッメー・マッリキー・ヴィパリーナ・マンニャターバーワ・ジーヴィタッサピ・シヤ・アンニャタッタ
私のもう命まででも変になりますよと
ですから何言うんですかとも
キン・パナメーナ・ウッパッジャッサン・ソーカ・パリデーワ
悲しむぐらいはなんで生まれないんでしょうかと
私の命そのものまで変になるかもしれませんよと
それでイダン・コータン・マハーラジェ・テーナ・バグワター・ジャーナター・パッサター・ラハカー・サンマー・サンブッデーナ・サンダーヤ・バーシタン
イダン・サンダーヤ・バーシタン
これについて語ったものですよと
あれは で 次に王様からピアテー・カーシ・コーサラ
王様の国二つあるんです
カーシ国とコーサラ国
で カーシ国っていうのはお釈迦様の国も入る大国なんです
全部取られてしまったんですね
コーサラはコーサラ王様の元々の国なんで
だから二つもその王様が管理していたんですね
これ大王ですよ 一応 カーシにはカーシの王もいるんだけど
でもこの王様の下で頑張らなくちゃいけない
で もうシャカ族の国も別でしたけど
そちらも王っていう人がいるんだけど
やっぱりもっと巨大な王の下で頑張っていたんですね
そこで あなたはこのカーシ・コーサラ国は好きですかと言えば
それは好きですよって答えるというふうです
エー
ワン・マッリキー・ピア・メー・カーシ・コーサラ・カーシ・コーサラ・ナーナン・マッリキー・アヌバーヴェーナ・カーシカ・チャンダナン・パッチャヌ・ボーマ・
マーラーガンダ・ヴィレーパナン・ダーレー・マーティ
これ王様がこのカーシ・コーサラ国のおかげで
アヌバーヴェーナのおかげで
カーシカ・チャンダナン
チャンダナンというのは
あの センダンであって
このもういわゆるこの香りのことなんですね
で この美しい香りを味わっているんだと
カーシーのセンダンの香り
だからそれは最高なものだそうですね
カーシーの服と あのカーシー
カーシー国っていうのはかなりこの上等な品物を作っていたそうですね
今みんなフランス製品
イタリア製品喜んでいるような感じでね
それにはインドではカーシーという
なんか人間あまり変わらないね
今イタリア製喜んで フランス製喜んで
カシミール地方はカッシー国があったけど
ちょっと地図を見ないとわからないね
今でもカシミヤの要望とか
当時でもそうでしたけどね
カシのインドの時でもね
おそらくカッシーに入ったと思いますね
すいません  うん  カシチャンダラと
うん  マハーラーガンダヴィレーパナン・ダーリーマーリっていうのは
この花やらいろいろお香をすったり
いわゆる何かおかしい言葉ですけど
こちらで言うのは 私はここまで贅沢して生きているのは
このカーシーとコーサラ国の政権でしょ
そういうことを言ってるんですよ
タン
キンマンニャシ・マハーラジャ・カーシコーサラナンテ・ヴィパリーナマ・アンニャター・バーワ・ウッパッジャヤン・ソーカ・パリジェワ・ドゥッカ・ドゥグナティ・パーヤサーティ
このカーシコーサラ国に何かあったら
異変が起きたらあんたどう思いますかと
カーシコーサラナニ・メ・マッリケ・ヴィパリーナマ・アンニャター・バーワ・ジーヴィッタッサピ・シヤ・アンニャタッタム
私の命にもどうなるかわからないんだと
命にさえ異変が起こるでしょうと
なんで悲しまないでしょうかと答えるんですね
そこで これですよと お釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
好きなものは苦しみを作ってくるんだと
だから国の国まで持ってきたら
王様にもどうにもならない
もうそれ以上は回る rzeczなくなっちゃって
そこでアッチャリヤン・マッリケ・アブタン・マッリケ
また不思議ですよと これは
ヤーワン・チャ・ソー・バガワー
なんでしたっけ パンニャーヤ・アティヴィッジャ・パンニャーヤ・パッサティ
パンニャーヤ二つ入ってるのちょっとおかしいんだ
マンニャーヤ・パッサティですか うーん
パンニャーヤで  マンニャーヤも入ります
パンニャーヤ一つだけで十分ですけどね
バガワー・パンニャーヤ・アティヴィッジャ・パッサティだけで文法はしっかりします
ミャンマー版はこのパンニャーヤリピートするんだと
この注がありますけどね
SOSISKTって何でしょうかね
SIはセヤマ版ですね
KTは書いてない Kはコープンニヤー
シンハラ文字の Tはテンノーマナスリ
それもシンハラ文字の K
とTはほとんど同じですよということで
ああ 和訳の方の中の三なんですけど
三百六ページの中の三にパンニャーヤ・パッサティのところをマンニーヤ・パッサティ
マンニーヤが入っちゃうと間違っちゃうんですよ
マンニーヤ・ヴィンニティ
マンニーヤを入れちゃうと全く逆の意味になるんです
なんかお釈迦様の知恵があるみたいやっていう非難になっちゃうんですよ
なんでそれ入れてるのかわかりません
ですから それでパンニャーヤをリピートするのはミャンマー版ですね
で シンハラ版ではマン入ってますね
パンニャーヤ・アティヴィッジャ・マン・パッセティ
その時は意味は通りますけど
でもこれは要らんと思いますけどね
パンニャーヤ・ブッタスはね
いらないですけど 捨てるわけにはいきませんね
マヌスクリプトにあるんだからね
そこでまあ意味言います
摩訶不思議ですよと お釈迦様がパンニャーヤ・アティヴィッジャ
アティヴィッジャっていうのは
この 通って 貫通して 知恵で貫通して見ているんだと
だから王様が驚いちゃうんですよ
いかにお釈迦様は真理
事実を語っているんですかと
私たちには見えないんだからね
一般的には やっぱりコーサラ国の王様はコーサラ国がすごいあって幸せでしょうね
だからコーサラ王様にとって全ての幸せ
幸福がコーサラ国二つが作ってくれてるんだからね
これが面倒くさいと思ったらわからないでしょうね
やっぱり見てみれば 自分に対して全ての苦しみがその国二つが作ってくれるでしょうし
個人として人間としての苦しみ
悲しみが自分の息子たち娘たちやら奥さんたちやらから出てくるでしょうね
かえってその人々が自分の好きなものでしょうしね
ですから 苦しみの種は好きなものですよというのは
確固たる事実ということね
よくもお釈迦様にバレてるんだっていう意味なんですね
普通人間には全くも気が付かないことということで
王様が驚くんですね そこでエーヒマンリキ・アーチャーメーヒーティ
どういう意味？ 清めよ
こいつはマッリカよ 清めよ
清めよって アーチャーメーヒーっていうのは
やっぱりもしかすると
まあまあ礼をしましょうという
謝りましょうということかもしれません
自分たちが間違っちゃったんだからね
自分が間違ったんだから
マッリカ夫人ではなくて
やっぱりお釈迦様は正しいだと
そこら辺でまた謝って
またやり直しということなんですね
まあそれ普通な それはまたひと筋取りなんですね
時々弟子が何でも先生に言うこと
はいそうです はいそうですって言うんだけど
時々先生に逆らう時もありますよ
逆らったところで弟子がもう間違ったと分かったら
もう分かった時点ですぐ行って
先生 この間本当に間違えましたというだけで
それでまたものすごくお互いの関係がものすごく強くなっちゃうんですよ
ああ そうかと 分かっていれば
先生が自分の弟子がね
もっと愛情が生まれてくるんですね
インドの師弟関係っていうのは親と息子の関係ですからね
いわゆる弟子入りは他人の子供たち弟子入りしますけど
一旦弟子入れたらもう全く息子のように扱っちゃうんですね
うん まあそういうこのまあもうアジア的なね
もうこの人間のこの互いにものすごい仲良くするっていうことはね
まあ文化の発達するたにも壊れちゃったんだけど
今は先生っていうのは職業でしょうしね
教えて給料もらって帰ると
だから生徒がお客さんですよ
あれでおかしくなるんですね
この間 NHKのテレビで東大の学生たち集めて
いろいろまた先生たちも来て
学校の先生やらなんとか昔
かなり前ですけどね ディスカッションになったんだけど
もうものすごく生徒たちがね
学生さんたちやら学校の先生たちがもう怒鳴ったりけなしたりするんですね
いろんな問題について
ちゃんと答え悪いんですよと
向こう先生 あんた方悪い
なんであんた方真面目に真剣に勉強しようとしないんだ
あんた方は悪いんだからですよと
あんた方の仕事でしょうと
そしたら向こうも いや
あんた方勉強あんた方仕事でしょうとか
そういうことで東大の人々がね
これはまあそれ間違ってるんだと
あんた方は私たちのおかげで食べてるんだよと
だから考えてみろ 私たちは客であって
あんた方は仕事をしているんだから真面目にやりなさいよと
私たちの立場はあんたかより偉いんですよと
それ外国人の人々いたんだけど
アメリカ人の若者がいて
ものすごくもうあなた方なんて東大ではなくても出て行けと
勉強する資格もないんだよと怒っちゃったんだけどね
それでアンタなんですかと
外人でとかなんとか言われちゃったし
もう単なる喧嘩でね テレビ番組だから何の知識もない
何の知恵もない もうただのくだらん番組でしたけど
その中でやっぱり人間の人格見えますから
やっぱりこれよりみんな苦しんでいるんだよと
だって僕ら考えちゃうと
父親は一人しかいないんだけど
いろんな先生たちから教えてもらっちゃうでしょ
みんな本当に父親なんですよ
だからすごい機嫌がいいんです
だから私たちはもういくら大人になっても
先生とか先生先生というのはものすごい愛情で言って甘えてもらっちゃうわ
もう何かもう大人になってからでも
大胆なことをして 何か失敗したっても
もう社会は批判するでしょ
なんであんたそんなことしたんですかと
そうするとこそこそと先生のところに行っちゃうんですね
行ったら先生が慰めてくれるんですよ
その分父親にできないんですよ
父親はただ育てただけだから
一人前にしたのは先生でしょうね
いろんなことを教えてくれて
そうすると先生が慰めてくれる
まあそんなことあったって
もうあんたね もうちょっとしっかりしなさいよとかね
あるいは自分が本当に間違ったならば
それはね そういうことじゃなくて
こういうことだよとかね
それで自分で解決できなければ自分で解決できる
自分では手に負えないんだったら
先生何のことなく出てきて生徒を守ってくれるんですよ
だからそういうところだから
この次の世代って若い世代にすごく元気で生きていられるんです
まあ多少失敗したっても
まあ落ち込むことはない
逃げ場がある 慰めてくれる人がいる
味方になってくれる人がいる
失敗したんだからと言って
その人を排除することはけしからんでしょうしね
だから自分のことを認めてくれる人がいる
それで自分は社会で失敗して
またやり直ししたいんだけど
できない場合は先生が出てきて
ちゃんとそこら辺で直してくれる
その関係をね 例えば私たちは同じ同士ですごい喧嘩になったところで
この我々のすごいすごい先生たちがすぐ間に入って
あなた方はお仲直しなさい
これ私の弟子ですよと
あんた方知らないんだけど
こいつはなかなかいい出来がいいんだよとかね
なんとか言ったら その推薦でまたうまくいくんです
ですから まあ自分の人生考えたって
かなり大胆なことをしたんですよ
若い時は でも あんた なんで若い頃にそんなことするんですかと言って
社会から批判が来るなと思っちゃうと
すぐ先生 その間に立つんですよ
何のことなく 間に立って
私がもう売った喧嘩を先生が取ってやっちゃうんです
それはその通りです あんた方何様ですか？と
そうすると こんな偉大なる先生に対しても
もう立ち上がりませんだから
みんなああまあと言ってすぐ認めちゃうんですね
だから 決して私の意見が私の力で言ったわけじゃないんです
結局は それですぐもう守ってくれるでしょうしね
それで私の場合もちょっとちょっと失敗やったら
こっちを出てきて その場合はこういうふうにしますよと言うで
そうするとこちらはもうはいはい
わかりましたとしか何も言えないでしょうね
自分をちゃんと守ってくれたし
それから自分のことを本当に心配してて
やってくれるんだからね
そこで日本にいた時でも
私はもう国のね いろいろ法律的にも束縛いろいろありましたからね
ある教授がこの文部省からね
あんたに何か言われたらね
気にせんでいいよと もう気にせんで私に言ってください
私は何とかしますからと
そう言われると まあすごく元気で頑張れることになるんです
だからそこはただ大学の教授で
大学に入って教えてもらうだけのことではなくて
ものすごくこのお互い人間として
もうずっと死ぬまで まあお互いに心配し合って
尊敬し合って生きてる人間関係なんですね
だから人間に本当にもう楽しく生きていければ
その関係っていうのはすごく必要なものなんですね
だから まあそれでもって
いろいろ悲しみ 苦しみが出てくる可能性もありますけど
やっぱりだから単なる商売目的のはね
先生っていうのは先生にもやる気がないし
自分に入るお金は何枚かとね
それ稼げるだけのことだからね
ですから このアジアにあるこの人間の感情っていうのは
西洋人が批判しますけど
最近読んだ西洋の記事で
政治のこと記事でしたけど
アジアの政治っていうのはもうむちゃくちゃで
我々にとってはもうどうも理解できないと
ということは言いながら批判ではなかったんだけど
やっぱりこの ASIAN POLITICS は ASIAN POLITICS だよと
それは WESTERN POLITICS とごちゃまぜに考えてはいけないんだと
だから西洋の人々がその点でいろいろ間違いを起こすんだよと
いう記事でしたけど なぜかというと
このある男が総理大臣とか何とか出て死んでしまっちゃったら
家にいた奥さんがすぐに何のことなく総理大臣になっちゃうんですよ
国会にいた次の先輩の議員ではないんです
それは西洋の見方から見ると
何なのかと 今まで国会にも入らなかったし
議員でもなかったし ただ総理大臣の奥さんだけでしたけど
やっぱりそれでも総理大臣死んじゃったら何のことなく
例えばバングラデシュみたいにね
イスラムの国にしたっても
もう大統領総理大臣なっちゃうでしょ
女の人が イスラムだったらもう女は社会に出てはいかないでしょうに
それまで厳しいんだけど
やっぱりアジア人だからね
そこら辺はもうなかなか消えないんですね
コーランもちょっと一歩下がっちゃうんで
その場合は そこで何考えてるかというと
この人間のこの愛情 感情なんですね
こういう人が我々をもうすごく指導して
リードして 政治家で国を治めていて
突然殺されたとか 死んじゃったとかなんかあったら
じゃあどうしようかと
その人に対する尊敬なんです
あれは 亡くなった人に対して尊敬だから
同じレベルで奥さんのことも尊敬すると
ですから どうぞあなたがやってくださいと
だから政治世界にはもう一年生かもしれませんだけど
二十年生の議員たちでも何のことなくもう助けてあげて応援する
それは西洋の立場から考えちゃうと
もうおかしいもいいところだよと思っちゃうんですね
でも その記事であったのは
そういうことは西洋人が批判してはいけませんと
そういうことで そういう国々がちゃんと自分なりの民主主義と
そういう国の管理とかやってるんだよと
それで悪いことももう当然起きますけどね
そういうふうなことでね
ですから こちらにこのこちら見えるのはそういう習慣なんですね
このコーサラ王様が隠れてでもお釈迦様に反対してたんですね
反対してただけではなくて
マッリガ夫人にも出ていけと
私のところから消えろと追い出すまでしたんだからね
自分がちょっと自分の先生に対して失礼な態度取っちゃったんですね
それで すぐまあなんのことなくすぐ謝って
じゃあ仲直りするということなんですね
そこでアタコーラージャパセナディコーサローッタヤーヤサナアーヤサナ
エー
カマンタングッタラーサンガカリトワエーナバガワーテーナンジャリンパナメットワティッカットゥムウダーナンウダーネーシーナモータッサバゴートーワラハトーサ
ッマーサンブッダッサナモータッサバゴートーワラハトーサッマーサンブッダッサアティ
そこでコーサラ様がすぐ立って
自分の衣をね 一つの私が着ているような感じにね
して お釈迦様のところに合掌して
三回ナモタッサという儀礼で
お釈迦様に礼をする  それでその経典は終わりますけど
こちらのたったワンポイントなんですよ
ずっとだからストーリーで全部まとめているんですね
それでこのワンポイントは覚えられるように
ずっと何回何回何回何回も繰り返されているんです
間違わないように 忘れられないように
それがピヤジャーティカーコソーカパ
ピヤジャーティカーピヤッパバワソーカパルディーワドッカドゥーマナスッパヤーサという一句行なんですね
そこでそれいろいろなところで使っているんですね
だからそのポイントというのは
やっぱりこの人間が なんで苦しみのかとね
なんで悲しむかと なんでいろいろそうやって悩むことがあるんでしょうかとかね
あっちこっち探すんだけど
自分の身の回りにあるんだからね
そのものが 苦しみの原因
悲しみの原因 頭が狂っちゃうと頭が狂った原因も
そうすると自分の周りにあるんですね
ほんのちょっと変えただけで
その危険性が出てくるんですね
わかりやすく言えば 我々は手榴弾というんですか
それを手に持っていて
また引き金にも指を入れているような感じなんですね
ちょっと蚊にでも刺されたから
こうしちゃうと これも引っ張ってしまっちゃうんですよ
手榴弾が手に糊でボンドでついていたならば
もうどうにもならないんですよ
爆発してしまっちゃうんです
だから我々の周りに財産もありまして
家族もいて 親戚もいて
いろいろそれで喜んではいるんだけど
必ずそういうものが変化はする
それは避けられない みんな死ぬ
一番大事なお母さんも死ぬ
お父さんも死ぬ 他の人々も死ぬと
財産もなくなると そういうものも絶対的にも永久的に止まってくれるということはないんでしょうに
ですから 子供が生まれて私は最高に幸福やと言ったら
その分不幸になることを覚えておけと
と私たちが仏教の立場から言いたいんですね
それに腹が立ったっても
それはもうそちらの間違いであって
ブッダの教えを覚えておけば落ち着いていられるんですよ
覚悟して生きていられるんです
[咳]たとえなんとかって自分の大俗な子供がね
犯罪を起こしたと あるいは事故を起こしちゃって死んでしまったと言っても
自分まで死ぬ必要はなくなっちゃうんです
まあそれはまあ世の中の起こるべきことやと思って落ち着いていられるという
このすごい人格というのは出てくるんですね
だから その教典の中でもう一つ言いたがっているところがあります
こんな単純な論理であろうとも
一般人にはわからないんだ
すごい考え方が単純でしょうに
でもじゃあわかるんだったら
あんた方も言ってみなさいというチャレンジなんです
だから高価な服やら高価なアクセサリーやら高価な家やらね
もう大変気に入っている家族やら両親やら友達がいると
まあ最高に幸福を得ているところでね
その人に聞いてみましょう
あなたにとって苦しみって何でしょうかと
何かわかってるんですかと
わかってないんですね
だから苦しみに陥った時
悩みに陥った時は全然解決方法何もなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうことで このこんな単純なことでもあなた方にわからないんだよという
だからブッダの知恵はそれはちょっと乗り越え
普通の人間よりは乗り越えてる知恵だよと
だから文系は私に聞きなさいよと
私はなんて 聞いた方があんた方のためになるんだよと
そういうことから わざわざとお釈迦様の言葉を言って
それに反対させちゃって
で 賛成する側には賭博師を入れちゃうんですね
それぐらいのレベルの知恵ですよと
知識ですよとね みんな得てる知識っていうのは
賭博の生き方は インド社会はもう全く認めない生き方ですからね
コーサラ王様もそれは否定する
賭博は良くないと そういう風に
そうすると王様がなんかちょっともうちょっと知ってるふりでしょうに
知ってるふりですけど
実際は同じだよと そこでマッリカ夫人の場合はマッリカ夫人にもなかなかひらめきは来なかったんだけど
彼女は仏教の信者さんだから
やっぱりその場合黙って聞いた方がいいやと
お釈迦様の言葉だから無駄話しないんだからね
やっぱり黙って聞いた方が安全だよと
でも仏教は自由な宗教だから
わからないところは聞くもんだよと
というところだから 自分でわからないんだから
正直に言って聞いてみたんですね
自分ではいけないんだから
一応代表を送って聞いてもらったんですね
聞いてもらったところ
じゃあ鵜呑みにしてそのまま王様に喋ったかと
そうじゃないんです それは自分の環境の中で
王様に具体的な例でもう説得させたんですね
だからそこら辺でマッリカ夫人が自分の知恵をうまく使ってます
最初に出てきた孤児の人が
どうなったかわからん
どうなったかわからないですね
息子を亡くして  やっぱりこの教典は
その人のことよりも このマッリカ夫人の知恵とね
女性としてのもうバリバリと堂々とね
対等で活動するところやらね
お釈迦様のこの一行の解釈をしてあげることに教典がね
集中しているんだから
で いろいろまた質問ございますか
あんまり変わらんもんですね
人間  そうなんですね 昔からもう見てみると
大体頭は回ってないんですね
生涯愛情はずっと続けばいいけど
愛情ってクルッと返ったら憎しみにもなっちゃって
ブシュッとかやっちゃうかもしれない
だからそれでも危険ですよ
みんな平気で危険を考えないで 1側面だけ見る
一応原子力発電で考えた方がいいんですよ
原子力の発電所でも電気は作ってくれます
安く それはすごい便利
だけど全く同じレベルの危険もあります
それは両方考えなくちゃいけないんですね
でも今の日本だったら
その危険よりも電気がいるっていう方を取っちゃうでしょ
取っちゃうからどういうしっぺ返しが来るかわからない
だからそこはもう無知な見方だよと
だからそんなに だから例えばそんなにむちゃくちゃ電気使わなくてもいいでしょうに
だからある面で電気使え使えと応援するでしょ
電力会社が一生懸命使いなさいと言って
また電力 電力 エネルギー足らない
足らないとまた泣いたりする
どっちか どっちでしょうかねと
そこで我々は節電しちゃうと
もう赤字だよとまた泣く
たくさん電気使うと節電しなさいとまた言う
どんなものにせても同じこと
例えば車会社がね なかなか大変だよと
売れないんだと言って一生懸命売ろう売ろうとする
それで政府ももう買うように我々をいじめる
お金なんで貯金してるんですか
買いなさい 買いなさいと
という風にして それで車買っちゃうと
みんなもうガソリン使わなくちゃいかんでしょう
そうすると地球の温暖
温暖化になんであんた方協力してくれるの？とまた我々に文句言う
こっちは温暖化に協力しなければ車使わないと
自転車で行くぞと 電車で行くぞってことになっちゃうでしょうに
そうするともうあんた方は何やってる？もうトヨタが潰れてるんだよとまた言うんですね
だからもうそれが経済学ですかね
こちら何か潰れていると
こちらから部品持ってそこ立てる
あ こっち潰れた じゃあこちらから持ってまたここを作ると
永久的にどちらも出来上がってないでしょうね
だから全部そういうシステムになってるんですね
このもうどう見ても矛盾
矛盾 矛盾 矛盾ばっかりで
部分的に直そう直そうと思うから
だんだんだんだん綻びがまたまたまた来るみたいな
だからものすごいこのもう全面的に根本のところから思考から直さなくちゃいけないんですよ
直す必要あるのは思考なんですね
この人類の頭が悪いということ
欲だけで生きていると
欲と怒りだけで 儲かりましょう
敵を殺そう それしか思考
それでしょ？思考の衝動は
バカだよね やっぱりこの二千五百年から我々をこうやってやってきたってもね
もっと前 人間にはすごい文明
文化ありましたから 跡形もなく消えている文明文化もね
地球上にありましたし
だからどちらにしても文明は完璧に破壊するまでこの思考を持っていくんですよ
言って人類はもう完全に破壊になるんです
それはもう避けられない
だけど だからといって
じゃあ答えがないんですか？人間というのは運命的で
もう必ず人類が破壊だけで
お釈迦様そうじゃない
道があることはあるんだよと
あんた方は使わないだけですと
言って この人類にこの道教えてるんです
教えてるんだけど それは理解しないで
またブッダの教え変えちゃうんでしょうに
それでまた単なるもう信仰だけで仏教終わってしまっちゃう
御利益の話やら信仰だけでね
それこそブッダに対するものすごい冒涜なんですよ
ブッダっていうのはすごい哲学者で
もう 人類みんなもう改良してあげようと
これも別に出家論語ったわけでもなくてね
みんな人類に だからお釈迦様最初からこの教えは人間
神々 全ての人類に 全ての生命に幸福の言葉だよと
だから言って広げてくださいと弟子たちに言ったんですよ
バフジャナヒターヤ バフジャナスカヤ
すべての王政の人々の幸福のために
王政の人々の安らぎのために
喜びのためにアッターヤヒターヤ
アッターヤっていうのはもうこれが意味あるもので
メリットのある道で デーワマヌッサラナ
人間だけではなくて 人間より他の生命であると誰にでもこれが道ですよと
それをみんなに言ってください
だから福音というキリストの言葉がありますね
福音と言えばブッダの言葉だけなんですよ
ブッダが福音を語ったんだけど
人類はブッダに対する態度は何ですかね
全て苦しみやと言ってるんだから
あれはもうすごい否定的やとかね
全て幸せやというのは嘘でしょうに
だから嘘を語ってくれということでしょうに
まあですから このまあ文字やら概念やらね
まあ概念が問題であって
まあだから概念がこの貪瞋痴で妄想概念なんですね
嘘を考えてるんですよ
客観的に調べる能力を持ってないんです
そこら辺問題なんですよ
だから人間概念考えることはもう止まることはできません
それも人間の能力ですから
でも嘘を考えちゃうと何の意味もないんですね
わかりやすい 例えば包丁っていうのは捨てましょうっていうのは意味がないんですよ
包丁を人殺すために使うことが良くないだけなんですね
ですから 我々はこの思考っていうのは
そうやって嘘を思考するために使っているんです
それは客観性ないんだからなんです
未来は見えないわけですから
これから日本がどうなるとか
世界がどうなるっていうのは全然わからないんですよね
まあまあ予測したっても意味がない
一応人間いくらかは仮定はできますけどね
仮定はあくまでも仮定ですからね
いわゆる推測っていうのはね
未来っていうのは今変えれば未来変えてしまっちゃいますから
未来は我々は創っているんだからね
うん 私たちが生き方を変えれば
それによって未来が変わってしまっちゃうんです
はい じゃあどうもありがとうございました